effortless manifestation
is
created with an effortless thought and
that is really a thought that's beyond
the mind which kind of sounds
contradictory but when we are in a place
of zero resistance
so we're not contracting anywhere no
resistance whatsoever
then one thought will manifest virtually
instantaneously
and if that thought is not contradicted
by any other thought i mean that's the
power that everybody has
you focus on a thought if you do not
contradict that thought it will manifest
and so
one of the things that we can do is we
want something or we want something to
occur we have a desire
and then
we visualize it or we think about it and
then
and then a whole lot of other thoughts
come in well how's that going to happen
and
you know you you didn't do that well in
that subject so how are you going to get
that job or
um things haven't worked out for you
before in that area so what makes you
think it's going to work out this time
and all of those kinds of thoughts which
are contradictory thoughts so every time
there's a thought like that it just
cancels it out it's it's resistance to
uh resistance to the thought that we had
we had basically planted to manifest and
so
so effortless manifestation is really
effortless thought
and
and having one thought that is not
contradicted by any other thought at all
and and so we can the more joy that
we're in
and the more happiness that the happier
we are
then our thoughts are going to be
effortless
you know they they
they just because when you enjoy and
happiness
you have very little resistance
you know or gratitude in gratitude you
have very little resistance that's why
when we're super grateful we'll have
tears come to our eyes
because we're letting go of resistance
so the the higher we can be in joy and
happiness or love or gratitude the less
resistance that we have
and that's the time i think to manifest
is when you're feeling that way not when
you're feeling oh i don't know
i don't know if i've got it right or
you know i've been waiting for this for
a long time and still not here all of
those kinds of things
if you can just get yourself up higher
into joy or into happiness or into
passion
then you're in a place where you don't
have as much resistance and
and then you're going to manifest but
basically effortless manifestation it
takes one thought to manifest just one
as long as it's not contradicted with
any other thought
and that's effortless manifestation
[Music]
i love that because so often when we go
to spiritual practices it's when we're
in a low place and we want something and
we're like i will do all of the rituals
and the moon practices and whatever you
got because i need the situation to
change but then when you're just joyful
and living your life you kind of forget
about those things yeah it's like how
can you bring in more of that
intentionality when you're feeling good
yeah and it was perfect what you just
said because i want this to change
and if you feel that that's full of
resistance
right i want this to change and i want
it to change now or i need this now and
that has a whole lot of resistance and
resistance you don't want because
resistance is basically saying i don't
have it yet
and uh and and so then
you're not going to get it so we need
that's why we need to let go of
resistance and in those higher
frequencies
there is not as much resistance there so
it's going to manifest a whole lot
faster so
yeah that and i think you know some
teachers say it's to manifest you don't
want to need something but it's just
it's just because the needing has
resistance in it that's all
kneading says i don't have it and as you
know for manifestation you have to
imagine that you have it already because
there's no time for any of the laws
law of attraction or any laws of physics
they're all operating in the present
moment so that's why you need to
visualize that you have your
manifestation you already have what you
want you've already got it traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world and the
quotient of change between the way you
normally feel in some alarm state when
you change your internal state and move
into that emergency mode you narrow your
focus
on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that's called the long-term
memory and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember experience our experience
is better because we can remember how
they feel and and that memory then
changes the person's biology so they
think neurologically within the circuits
of that experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person biologically has
changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because if the environment signals the
gene and that's the truth that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
for you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response
an image and an emotion a thought and a
feeling and you're conditioning the body
into the past well you're conditioning
the brain and body into the past and it
doesn't matter if the actual event
happened to you or not because if you
have the image what i'm hearing you say
it's still going to connect to the body
so like what's happening right now is
people are consuming probably more than
50 100 pieces of media talking about
trauma
in the world right now right that is
that causing more physical damage on our
bodies without actually having it
physically
hurt us well let me finish that thought
and then we can answer that question
mind-blowing so then you asked if is it
possible then that people can heal that
quickly in one week yeah because what if
they create an inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or joy or freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion
the stronger the emotion you feel from
that breakthrough the more you're going
to pay attention to the image in your
mind and now you're now beginning to
brand new circuitry in the brain and
your body's being conditioned into a new
future and the stronger the emotion you
feel the more you pay attention to the
picture the more you're conditioning the
body over time to the future instead of
the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally
then that emotion ultimately signals a
new gene
that
up regulates that gene to produce better
proteins and the person and all of a
sudden starts healing and we have
research to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells and
wow
just to signal stem cells to to suppress
um
uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress uh
inflammation that we have research to
show that you could change the number of
brain cells you have just by by doing
this properly and so now all of a sudden
a person
in four days
you can start to
reverse some of the damage you've done
in your body depending on the degree of
damage it sounds like but in four days
by
simply replacing
the imagery the visualization
the acknowledgement to a different
emotion an emotion of joy gratitude
peace perspective acceptance i'm
assuming these things a vision of your
future a vision of what you want that's
positive as opposed to a vision that is
tied to a negative event of the past
over and over every single moment of the
day
your body will start to heal your immune
system will start to heal and you'll
start to get you'll start to shift your
genes gene expression absolutely what is
this law of attraction so people think
that uh if you keep asking for something
in your head you know you keep thinking
about it even if you're meditating if
you keep visualizing it then one day
maybe that's the dumbest thing people
can do in their life
because
the most important thing in one's life
is
to create intensity without intent
the biggest problem today in the world
is we have take taken to western ways of
life that we've all become goal oriented
we want to get there
see right now if you set a goal in your
life let's say from where you are if you
set a goal how will you arrive at a goal
it's just an exaggeration of what you
already know isn't it can you set a goal
about something that you do not know
so that means
in your entire life only what you know
will happen nothing new will happen to
you what a terrible life is that
so the moment you start setting a goal
for yourself
you are fixing yourself to a mediocre
life
the important thing is to raise this
life to the highest possible intensity
life should unfold your genius should
unfold
then depending on the times we will do
what we have to do
in the world the brain is a computer
that's a clear fact and it has the same
functions and and systems as our silicon
conventional computer that people is
watching right now and so here's the
insight i get a brand new computer and
got out of the store and i push start
and it boots up what does that mean the
screen lights up i say oh great got a
brand new computer let's do a drawing
let's do a story a spreadsheet
and i say no i can't do it i say why not
you got a brand new computer say not
until i put programs in the computer can
i use that computer
and so i say oh and then after i got the
programs and then i can type and i can
interface the computer but i without a
program i can't do anything
the human brain as a computer gets
programmed starting in the last
trimester of pregnancy through age seven
because the brain function is not high
enough for consciousness most of the
time it's a little lower and i say
that's what we said theta hypnosis i say
why is it relevant the answer is very
important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like
an infant can't read the book i go no
the infant brain is actually like a
video recorder it watches the mother it
watches the father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can
work the computer and do what it wants
okay so i basically say so it started in
utero this is how
a mother can play music through her
abdominal wall you know put the speaker
there
and repeat that music and guess what
when the baby's born she plays that
music the baby instantly knows that
music or the father talks to the baby
through the abdominal wall
and repeats this and when the baby is
born the moment the father says
something the baby will know which one
the father is because it already
memorized this stuff it memorizes what
the mother eats ah because of that
nutrition coming through i say how does
all this work simple
we talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics when i go so why
is it relevant i say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development i go the
mothers so i go so why is that relevant
well if she's having an emotional
response that's chemistry and i say
she's feeling that emotion whether it's
wonderful love or fear i go so why is it
relevant that blood with the same
chemistry of the mother is going into
the fetus i go why is it relevant the
fetus feels what the mother feels if the
mother is under stress and the fetus is
getting an experience that life is very
difficult out there if the mother is
feeling love and support and everything
then the life is easy for the fetus it
started learning in the last trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and i go so why is
irrelevant i go
once i get past h7 my consciousness can
type on the keyboard so i can program
what i want and then here comes the
monkey wrench and the monkey wrench is
this the conscious mind which types can
think and you go so what i go thinking
is inside
you know
if i ask you jennifer i say tell me what
you're doing uh you know on tuesday yeah
and right away
you can tell me but you'd have to think
oh tuesday what am i doing i do that i
say what's the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and i so
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore i said oh my god i'm going to
crash the car because of my
consciousness is inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like i said
why is it relevant i go
now science is recognized 95 of the day
is the average person's amount of
thinking like i said why is it relevant
well the conscious mind has your wishes
and desires and subconscious as your
programs is your life coming from your
wishes and desires i go five percent
ninety-five percent of your life is
whatever the hell the program you got
from that seven years is going to play
and if you've got a program that's not
supporting you then 95 of the day your
behavior will not support you because
that program doesn't encourage you okay
uh i always give the audience the same
story for 40 years now
and you know the story but i'll tell
your community because you have a friend
and you know your friend's behavior and
you happen to know your friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell your afraid to go
hey bill you're just like your dad i
said back away from belt because i know
what bill's going to say the first thing
he said how can you compare me to my dad
i'm nothing like my dad in the audience
laughs i go that's the most profound
story in the world right now i'll tell
you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad who's the one that doesn't
see it bill i got how the hell is that
how do i go because when bill is
thinking he lets go of the control
and while he's thinking the behavior is
playing but because he's not even
looking out at his own behavior he
doesn't even see his own behavior yes so
in his mind no i'm not like my dad i go
but everybody else can see you behave
like you're dead you're the only one
that can't see it and i go so why is it
relevant and the answer is simply this
we are all bill
we all have beliefs wishes and desires
and then we have to say how come i'm not
manifesting the world i want how come
i'm not as healthy as i want to be how
come not creating the life i want if my
mind is the creator and i go it is the
creator but then i tell you but which
mind are you operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires
95 of the day the subconscious programs
are automatically playing
i go what if those programs are not any
good i go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so i very simply i wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today i'm
going to go find love today i'm going to
get healthy today i'm going to get the
best job and then at five o'clock you
come home and go it didn't happen it
didn't happen and i go then what does
that person think because they're like
bill they go oh everything's against me
the universe against me
this person is responsible that person
is responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires i go
no all day long you were shooting
yourself in the foot with your own
behavior and you didn't even know where
the gun was coming from it was in your
own hand
and i say so why is it relevant we have
been programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside
when the truth is no
95 the day we were playing programs that
did not support us and as a result the
end of the day we didn't get that
support but we
didn't see it why subconscious was below
conscious was controlling your life your
conscious mind is i'm going to be
healthy i'm going to fall in love and i
go that's great but that's five percent
of the day yeah but 95 i go i'm coming
from a different program and so when you
look at your life and this is a
beautiful part you can say what are my
programs i just want to help people
right away i'll tell you what your
programs are you say wait how do i know
i was being programmed before i was born
i was programmed from zero to one can
you tell me what program you got when
you were zero no can you tell the
program you got a one no
can you tell me the program at two no
about three you might say oh i remember
some things but i say you've been
essentially programmed with no awareness
of the program so you didn't even see
the program and now i say so what is
your program you go
i wasn't there
now i give you the answer and you're
ready
95 of your life comes from the program
your life is a printout of your program
look at your life right now i'm going to
tell you this very simple
the things you like that come into your
life they come in because you have a
program to bring them in yeah the things
you want health relationship good job
your struggle you're working hard you're
putting a lot of effort in i'm gonna
make it happen i'm sweating i'm gonna
work hard
why are you working so hard and the
answer is simply this
your own program doesn't support that
you're trying to override the 95 of the
day that that negative program is
playing with five percent effort going
oh i wanted to be successful i go yeah
and 95 of the day
you got whatever you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and a very interesting fact is this for
400 years the jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
i go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say
give me a child until it is 7 and i will
show you the man.
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as i said science has said the
first seven years you're in theta
program
that's where you're learning then i said
but what about the rest of you'll have
to go 95 of the rest of your life
program so if i can control the first
seven years i control the rest and
that's what they said give me a child
until seven i will show you the man
meaning if you let me do the first seven
years of programming i will tell you how
that child's life is going to work out
when it comes to manifestation it's very
important to manifest alongside the
universe because there's uh
you can look at it as two parts of this
energy which is one is the collective
which is you connected and intertwined
with every ongoing where people can
refer to as god or universe or whatever
and um your own energies the alignment
with it all so it's very important to
get into absolute alignment and when it
comes to absolute alignment there are
three main parts that is very crucial to
being able to attract anything you want
whether that be the relationship of your
life or whether that be
finances or money or a new house a new
car whatever it is that you want to
manifest it's very important to align
these three m's and so um the first m is
understanding how to align what is
happening in the mind and when we talk
about mind it's not just about saying oh
i do think about my goals every single
day because of course you do why would
you not right but that is on a conscious
level because if we understand on the in
in the brain it's split into the two
parts of the uh the subconscious and
then the conscious
and the interesting thing is that ninety
percent of our manifestations actually
happen from the subconscious so it's
very important to know how to reprogram
our subconscious mind to manifest
effortlessly and that's why actually we
have an event coming up called
manifesting miracles where we'll be
diving into and working with you step by
step in terms of how to reprogram the
subconscious mind you can do this
through certain things like
cognitive reframing by getting rid of
the old belief systems throwing it out
and being able to do things like healing
meditations uh shifting your vibrations
energetically and being able to release
that trauma
or even things like affirmations but i
wouldn't really recommend doing any type
of affirmation that you just find on
youtube why because it needs to be
specific to
um counter all the negative thoughts and
or disappointment beliefs that you may
have and so that's why at manifesting
miracles we help you create
personalized affirmations so that it
suits your needs and your needs only and
so it's very important to
deal with that mind and reprogram that
subconscious mind i just want to say if
you guys want tickets for the next
manifesting miracles which is happening
very soon we've got a huge huge huge
discounted ticket right now which is
only for is it 22 or something
22 dollars so um usually our three day
events is like around nine nine seven
dollars or nine around a thousand
dollars um but right now we're doing a
very special after lockdown special at
just 22 so um make sure to click on the
link in the first first link in the
description it's gonna be virtual you
can tune in right from home anyway let's
get back into this so
once you've aligned what's happening in
the subconscious mind it's really
important to work on the second part and
i believe that a lot of people miss this
part out and what does that mean the
mechanics
now what am i referring to when i talk
about mechanics i'm referring to
um
the the actions you take the strategy
you actually use um how you can actually
take these micro manifestation mapping
and and this is also what we do at
manifesting miracles on day two we'll be
doing a whole timeline mapping so that
you can actually uh micromanage all the
manifestations from
manifesting the micro into
actually seeing how everything comes
together and your big miracles actually
manifest in your life right so what is
important is a lot of people think that
manifestation is some woo thing where
you just sit around and and and just and
pray to the universe and wishful
thinking and hopefully you'll be able to
manifest anything in your life which is
not true
because what's very important is also
the action you take actually the hint is
already in the word law of attraction
right so you got to take some form of
action but the big problem is people
don't know how to align the thing they
want to manifest with what sort of
action should they even be taking
and that's why on day two of manifesting
miracles we usually cover breaking it
down for you it doesn't matter what you
want to manifest in your life
it could be
the relationship of your dreams right it
could be a new career it could be a a
freedom lifestyle it could be to be able
to travel the world it could be to be
able to contribute do more charity work
or whatever it is and have that freedom
to be able to do so
there needs to be a timeline mapping
happening because clarity is power so
that's why
the second thing that is required is
understanding how to align it with your
mechanics now the final thing is what a
lot of people
are not so familiar with and i refer to
as mastery what does that mean actually
mastery is the is the collective energy
it's saying
how do you
not uh
not just think that it's just down to
you
uh that manifests what you want because
there is something that we are
coinciding in that we are in oneness
with you probably i heard people talk
about be one with the universe or trust
the universe or flow of the universe
but how do you actually tap into that's
part of the intuition
how do you actually grow spiritually i
mean when i went up
into the mountains for my initiation
with my master grandmaster aksha
it was a very profound experience
because for the first time understanding
what is this kundalini awakening people
are talking about what is this pineal
gland and activation and third eye and
why go out of dimension to be able to
manifest greater because the connection
actually happens there that's why a lot
of the time people have this saying they
say man makes his plan and god has his
plans for you why because if your vessel
is not ready and it's not aligned with
what the divine
creator creation universe has for you
right then you're kind of working
against the current that's probably why
some of you may have been trying trying
trying trying extremely hard to manifest
something but it's not quite working out
for you
so it'll help two types of people the
first type is the ones who aren't able
to to currently manifest what they want
or those of you who are finding it a
little bit slow and you want to speed up
your manifestations by understanding
this part of the puzzle understanding
how to manifest with the universe
that is when we can speed everything up
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o
a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it and
believing in it is already a big step
ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're gonna focus on your new goal your
new habit the new thing that you want
into your life amazing you believe that
it's possible amazing you're putting up
a vision board with it on your wall
amazing you're researching and watching
videos like this every day amazing
that's great that's the first starting
point but nothing happens until you take
action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just going to be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals you have
to do something i look at my youtube
channel as an example uh my main channel
i want to get the 10 million subscribers
that's my next goal right we hit one we
hit two i gotta hit 10. uh at the rate
that we're growing it's not fast enough
like it's gonna take me way too many
years to make it happen so i need to
apply more pressure against it so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
000 videos imagine doing split tests on
all of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other ones doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day i don't know
but it's happening through action right
so it starts with the idea if you have
the idea but you're not taking action
you won't get results if you just have
the action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear direction most
people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your lives you go watch netflix
all day when you get home for five hours
and then go to sleep right you're a
professional consumer but you're
consuming
uh wasteful content
just entertaining content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you're not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's the
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it true manifesting is about
receiving what is of the highest good
for all
this is probably one of the most
profound
ways to look at life
when we stop expecting things to be the
way that we think they should be when we
stop forcing outcomes and when we start
allowing what is of the highest good to
be our only agenda our only intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop
praying for what we think we need and we
start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what well how will
i get what is of the highest good but
how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one
number two being in the expectation of
what you think things should be is
another block to your manifesting power
and your super attractor power which is
what i call it because your expectations
are limiting the possibilities your
expectations are limiting the highest
good as this card says so when we start
to pray for what is of the highest good
rather than intend and pray for what we
think we need that's when the universe
can conspire with what it is that is of
the highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your ass
i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being
being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself
you said i want to embody the feeling i
want to embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you got to
pick up the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel i want to explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was go just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type done the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable that's stepping out of the
box that's doing things different and we
don't like to do things different
because it causes a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said
and you know something
my income went from four thousand to 175
000 in a year and then i took it over a
million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here many
people come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out and make
a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help
the more reasons you will have to become
and stay a millionaire and here's the
third thing and this is so important
many people think well i'm just going to
float around and manifest millions i'm
just going to sit at home with my sofa
and manifest millions if you want a job
you go out and look for a job if you
want a new home you go out and visit new
homes
you want a partner you better go out and
put yourself in front of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hairdryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi
dollar company they didn't invent a new
product well they sort of did they took
an existing product they made it so much
better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how they've been deluded by
these manifestation rooms sit at home
and chan on shanti and money will fall
from the heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to man you what could
you possibly do to make money remember
that woman who changed the face of a
floor mop they made a movie about her
and she became a millionaire and she was
a housewife but one day she was mopping
her floor you know this is not really a
good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made a millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home the
best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success of course they can take time out
but you see when you do what you love
and love what you do it never really
feels like work i love what i do
i do what i love i often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe
you can be a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and you said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out
of the notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to use the law of attraction check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there now this is a mind
game you must understand the mind if
you're really going to make it happen
and when you study this and start to
understand it
then you attract according to the
vibration you're in and you'll start to
understand that